Oh, what's up?
- All right.
- You good?
- Who's this?
- Oh, this, uh,
Michelle, my n---a,
this my n---a, James--
- Michelle Nychole.
- That's Michelle Nychole,
Stevie's ex.
And just like the 2Pac movie,
she's gang related.
Michelle Nychole
has the same problem
as many female gang members.
She can't seem to
meet the right guy,
and get up out that life.
- The guys that
Michelle attracts
and that she's attracted to
bring just more
drama in her life.
D--she's always--
- Like what you did.
- I mean, yeah, but
I--I'm a hood n---a,
so, like, you feel me?
Like, I--I ain't exempt
from what I'm saying.
- [laughs]
- You know what I'm saying?
I'm just saying, you should
date a different type of dude--
or--and/or girl,
you know how you get down.
- What are some deal breakers?
- Gay.
- Gay, okay.
But aren't you bi?
- Yes.
- I get it.
What's the best date you had
with a hard, banged-out?
- The best date I had was...
- Was with me.
We was breaking in
cars that night.
- How you know
what I was gonna say?
- 'Cause I already know.
'Cause it was when...
- Is this real?
Is this really real?
- So we breaking in cars, right?
I'm like, "Baby, you need some
beat for your whip." She like...
- I did, in my Honda.
- "Hell yeah, I need some beat."
I see one, boom.
It got beat, right?
So I crack it, bam.
Right, I get in there, right?
I'm just like,
"Come on, come on, come on."
It was, like, exciting--
[bell dings]
- The views of Stevie J and
Michelle Nychole in no way
reflect the views of
James Davis, Comedy Central,
or its parent company Viacom.
Let's face it: robbery dates
just aren't healthy.
Homegirl needs our help.
We're gonna set you up
on a speed date.
We're gonna get you
some other options.
That's what we're gonna do--
- And calm down, too.
Don't be aggressive
in your dates.
Just be you.
- I'm like--
- I'm not saying
change Michelle Nychole.
But I'm just saying
don't scare 'em off
'cause you know how you get...
- How am I supposed to know?
- Don't hit nobody.
Just relax.
- I'm not gonna hit nobody.
- You--you sure?
- No promise is
meant to be broken.
- Time for Michelle Nychole
to dive into
a whole new dating pool.
- Hello, I'm Zack!
- Oh, wow.
- Am I coming in too hot?
- Uh, yeah, you just...
- I'm sorry, I just--
- A little loud, it's crazy.
- You know, I just get excited.
- Joey. Nice to meet you.
- Michelle Nychole.
- Oh, I love that name.
I also like those
burgundy J's you got on.
I got some white ones.
I just got 'em.
- Nice!
- Okay, okay.
- He winning, we good.
- Jordan talk.
- Let me see 'em.
- Well, they're J's.
They're not, like,
one of the number ones,
but Jordan's on it...
- What are those?
- You got two kids?
- Two children.
I'm not a billy goat.
- I am a comic book dealer.
- We said no dealers,
but I guess
we can make an exception.
- If a guy touched my ass,
would you fight him?
- What kind of guy
are we talking about here?
- What do you mean what kind
of guy, does it matter?
Because if a girl
touched your ass,
then I'd whoop her ass.
So you not gonna stand up
for a man for me?
- No, I--I would,
you know, say something.
- What the [BLEEP]
are your hands doing, bro?
- Um, so my nails, uh,
I fell asleep at the manicurist,
and, uh, my friends pranked me.
They paid $20
for them to get painted.
Do--can I see your nails?
[soft laugh]
Oh, wow, those are nice.
Did you...
- You're lying, because
I bite my [BLEEP] nails.
Now you're a liar.
- I'm not lying.
I would never--I wouldn't--
- You just told me
my nails are nice.
And I know I have [BLEEP] nubs,
so you're a liar.
[laughter]
I like Roscoe's.
Maybe we can, uh,
meet up at Roscoe's.
- Yeah, anytime, you know?
Like, for real, get my number.
- Oh, this is happening.
It looked Vin Not-So-Diesel
was closing the deal.
But you'll never guess
who Michelle Nychole chose.
- You're low-key hot.
[soft laugh]
[bomb drops]
- She chose Zach, y'all.
So I hooked Zach
and Michelle Nychole up
with a his and her spa date.
Swag.
- My first impression
of Michelle Nychole was, uh,
she's super intimidating,
but, like, also, like
super attractive,
just, like, so smart.
I've never met someone in a gang
or around a gang.
Uh, but I think it's cool
that she's a part of one.
[laughter]
[upbeat music]
This is definitely
my first time dating a mom.
I think it's cool
that she's so responsible and...
- Hey, guys, Michelle--
[soft chuckle]
Michelle Nychole, uh,
got arrested.
- Are you serious?
Michelle Nychole got arrested.
- She's not here
because she's in jail, so.